[Music]
hey how's it going everybody a lot has
been happening lately and it's largely
due to ant-man and the wasp coming out
in just nine days it's been really great
because Kevin Feige has been talking
about ant-man and the loss Pilat has
been doing a lot of interviews and in
turn many people are asking him about
Avengers four and phase four of Marvel
so in this video I'm going to talk about
a theory of my own that I actually think
has a good possibility of playing out in
the MCU before we get started don't
forget to subscribe to my channel so you
can stay up to date on all the theories
and news regarding Avengers 4 so for
this theory two things are very
important that Kevin Feige said in
interviews the first thing he said is
that the MCU going forward phase four
will be all about new characters the
next thing he said is that going forward
with phase four half of the heroes will
be female so these are both very
important things that the president of
Marvel Studios Kevin Feige himself has
said the next thing is we know that some
of the actors that play the original
Avengers their contracts are up and as
far as we're concerned none of them have
renewed them with the exception of
Scarlett Johansson because we know that
we're going to get a solo black widow
movie but I want to specifically talk
about Robert Downey jr. and Iron Man he
is most likely leaving the MCU whether
he's going to die in Avengers 4 or he
retires at the end I don't know but we
know it's most likely the end for him
and I don't think that they're going to
try to replace him I don't think they
really can he's the first and original
Avenger in the MCU and Robert Downey jr.
has done such an amazing job
portraying him that you just really
can't replace who he is but what you can
do is bring in a character that still
wears the same type of suit
now obviously from the title you all
know that I'm talking about Sheree
however I do not think she's going to
become Iron Man per se again I don't
think anyone can really replace Iron Man
and I don't think they're going to try
but I do think that there
to introduce ironheart Kevin Feige has
already stated that they're going to
bring in new characters to the MCU that
you might have seen in the comics and
honestly I think it fits perfectly in
the comics there is a girl named RiRi
Williams RiRi Williams first made her
appearance in invincible Iron Man vol 2
number 7 RiRi is a 15 year old girl who
is a genius she's also an inventor and
an engineer does this sort of sound
familiar sounds just like Shuri RiRi
Williams at 15 years old gets a
scholarship to the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology in her dorm
using materials that she stole from
campus she manages to build her own
Ironman suit she eventually uses the
Ironman suit and prevents two inmates
from escaping the New Mexico State
Prison in the process her suit gets
damaged and she continues to work on it
and in the meantime Tony Stark hears
about her and wants to meet her of
course he meets with her and when he
does he tells her that he supports her
being a superhero ultimately Tony Stark
lets her use Tony Stark's lab as her
base of operations he even gives her an
AI just like Tony Stark has Jarvis and
Friday and RiRi takes on the title of
Iron Heart the female version of Iron
Man so to me it seems super easy to
switch riri Williams with Shuri
they're basically the same person as it
is they're both young girls who are
geniuses inventors and engineers and not
to mention Shuri already build suits she
builds them for Black Panther and I'm
guessing with what Condon technology she
could probably easily build an Iron Man
suit and I can also easily see Tony and
Cherie working together in Avengers for
sure he giving Tony symbol Condon
technology
Tony will obviously be impressed with
how smart sure he is and she's gonna
remind him an awful lot of his self when
he was young and she was already pretty
heroic in Avengers for trying to save
vision and kind of fighting off Corvus
glaive there in the end and not to
mention she put up a pretty good fight
against kill monger and black panther so
Tony's going to see that she has
everything that it takes to be Iron Man
and that she's probably somebody that he
might want to pass the mantle down to
because like I said in the beginning of
this video it's pretty much coming to an
end for Robert Downey jr. playing Tony
Stark plus in the beginning of infinity
war Tony was pretty much telling pepper
that hey I'm gonna promise no more
surprises
I think he was basically saying that
yeah it's about time for me to hang up
the old Iron Man suit so sure he already
wanted to go to America into the real
world outside of Wakanda and at the end
of Black Panther 2 Chawla took her there
so it seems like a perfect opportunity
and it seems like it lines up very well
that Sheree would take the mantle of
Iron Man or Iron Heart and not to
mention if they did it this way it would
enable Robert Downey jr. to come back
and make cameos as Tony Stark
because again how could you really
replace him as Iron Man he is Iron Man
so there is my theory I think that
Sheree will become Iron Heart I think
they're just going to have her take the
place of the character riri Williams and
I think we're going to be introduced to
Iron Heart at the end of Avengers 4 I
think she's going to help out the
Avengers and defeating Dana's so there
you have it let me know what you all
think in the comments below and also hit
me with some of your own theories if you
have them don't forget to hit the like
button before you leave and please
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on Avengers 4 theories news
all things Marvel DC and superhero thank
you so much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you
[Music]